so we had the great game last night with
the Rose Bowl and I thought that Florida
State Michigan in the Orange Bowl was
awesome as well as a Florida State beats
Michigan 33 32 that was on Friday night
head coach of the Seminoles Jimbo Fisher
joining us coach how's your morale good
it's always good at the end of season
like that and it's gonna be awesome you
got nine months when I can't criticize
you Nicole although find a way coach we
know that they'll find a way right
did you watch the game last night in the
Rose Bowl probably 80 85 percent over
yes that's crazy though there that like
rollercoaster back and forth and you had
one of those games with Michigan but as
a coach in the moment how do you sort of
stave off something or take control of
something when you can just see
everybody saw momentum changing last
night a couple of times how do you how
do you defuse that as a coach well I
think people wanted you to use it on the
sidelines there's you there's a couple
few words or key phrases you will say to
your players but that doesn't do it what
changes the momentum is your preparation
before as a youth to be able to get into
that mindset that okay we have to change
momentum people think you change it on
the side you don't you change it in the
preparation going up but there's key
words or phrases that you will say to
your players that kind of make them come
back to oh okay we prepared to it and
you know this is like your show my game
whatever if you feel like you've had a
preparation for something that's
happened then you feel you can adjust to
it and and do what you need to do to
change it and I think that's the key and
I think what you saw last night it's
crazy this sound was two teams that were
very well prepared because they were
both able to change momentum when they
had to because they probably had
prepared for it very well going in what
are you going to miss most about Dalvin
cook you know of course everyone says
the great runs and it just did first the
dynamic of watching and running going
all guys just did it again you know I
mean you just look at yourself and how
many times I just gotta make this many
big plays like for instance he had 19
touchdowns this year
his average touchdown run with 26 and a
half year
I mean what is it was just crazy I've
never been in but the thing I really
will miss the most about it it's his
lack of entitlement his work ethic and
his ability to affect the other guys on
the team because of his personality in
this demeanor was there any thought of
him not playing in that game was there a
discussion no you don't understand I
mean I mean because if he would have
ever thought we had if we have a great
relationship a very open relationship
that I've spent a lot of time with him I
didn't talk to different players
different thoughts and I mean it was
never even thought of discussed anything
of any sort and he could have but we
have a very open platform if Alvin's the
guy that you know you stand it to you go
to the park and you're a player you're
you're playing college ball or high
school ball whatever and you're the star
player and it gives it the parkour play
and then you go up to have me walking to
the park and you may be walking with
your girlfriend or your friends and
you're chilling out and you're just
having a day off and all of a sudden the
game breaks out and they roll the ball
out and they start playing within five
minutes Alvin would be in the middle of
the game if that makes any sense I mean
he's the guy when the ball rolls out to
play no matter where it's that he's
going to play that's Philly yeah we had
him on a couple of weeks ago we loved
him we just thought that he had a great
sense of humor just seemed like a good
kid and you know you're lucky to have
him and now he goes to the NFL we're
talking to Jimbo Fisher Florida State
head coach would you rather have a
season end like yours did or like Ohio
State's did well of course you say like
ours did because it's still
disappointing and you end in a win
that's one of the great things about
college football that I prayed and folks
that we don't with the playoffs are
wonderful but college football you build
your teams a lot of times awfully and
you don't have to always end in a loss
like every other sport does and going
into the fall season I think it was very
good for our kids to realize how they
could flip the strip how they could do a
lot of things at ease things even when
certain goals were taken away and for
your development your program it's much
better but at the same time I don't take
anything away from high say because they
had one to four shots to win the whole
thing which is all to me ultimately what
you want to go so people say you know
it's disappointing pay
hi state was still in the national
semifinal with the chance to win a
national championship so I think both
seasons were extremely successful play
analyst here for me coach
Clemson we lost by 3 to Clemson back at
the end of October going against Alabama
if Nick Saban called and said hey where
would you where do you see some weakness
here where would you attack first of all
would you give him information if Nick
Saban called and Nick and I are very
close I'm an extremely close but you
know I still have a lot of respect for
that bo in our conference what goes on
and Nick wouldn't do that I mean here
watch the film and make his own
adjustment like most 99% of people do
but you know I think very unique dynamic
because you know at multiple
quarterbacks have always caused Alabama
problems I mean by the cause of if I
said Alabama causes everybody problems
yeah guys who can really throw the
football I mean we act like that's a I
don't know me here's what make this [ __ ]
Sean special and in a lot of ways I mean
he he controlled the tempo of the game
and he has the ability to when it's up
its up ones down it's down and bring him
back and keep him an even keel no matter
what and I think you know even argument
the best player in the country one of
them and he is a phenomenal player to
compete against I mean it really is but
his ability to throw in the pocket his
ability to add to key plays alive and
then to pure run and there's a
difference between an ad-lib guy who can
keep plays alive a lot of the runners
can't do that they could have designed
quarterback runs he has the instincts to
do both and then they have the design
runs and of course they're going to use
them it makes it very unique and it's
gonna have a huge challenge the other
thing is Mike wins because then how do
you get the extra guy the boxing on the
quarterback run you got to play Mike
Williams 101 which makes it very cold
and then Deion cane and they're quick
screen and then Gulman can run the
football so Clemson's going to get
theirs
I think the key matchup as much as
anything is going to be how much Alabama
scores just like last year no one
thought Alabama would score 45 you know
and make the plays on that side because
Clinton is very good up front they have
experienced linebackers in the secondary
but but you know we underestimate and
then with Nick and I coach with Nick a
long time next not a guy who
in my opinion in his team they don't
have to go score 50 and beat you by 44
40 45 points he does what he has to do
to control the tempo and the tempo the
game is very important and it 2047 is
just as important pressive to him is
it's 45 to nothing and the how he's
controlling the game and how he's
playing how they often plays the defense
the defense to the office I think that's
the true genius and how he plays and I
think the dynamic is going to be he
creeps in wow man we didn't score a lot
well maybe they did but did they try as
hard and I'm saying not saying they
didn't watch them was really good on
defense but there's certain dynamics of
a game that Nick will control the tempo
if he knows he's got things in hand so
that to me is gonna be key and I think
again special things which it was last
year the aunt I know they had to
remember they got really 14 points off
special team I got an onside kick last
year and they returned to kickoff for a
touchdown just like in our national
championship game a couple year well we
want it 13 we returned to kick off a
touchdown to hit a fake punt something
in special things will be is important
in this game it is the office for the
defense I think the keys gonna be
Alabama's offense against Clemens
defense and anything that happens in
special teams in my opinion when do you
start preparing for Alabama in the
season opener for your next September it
won't be long we'll have our handle it's
on him already break them down we do the
first three four phone and that's
something I am you know we learn for the
dynamic of it because you bring people
in you analyze and that's two things we
got a head start breaking the first
three to four opponents down for next
year and we'll start here in Daniel
whatever recruiting as this main staff
will be out but our G A's and all that
will have those feelings broke down when
we get back incentive where we'll hit it
run it so we can have all the dynamics
and things that we want to implement for
our spring practices and you know
brought in the spring practice things we
have to develop for those game plans and
in that dynamic and then be ready to go
cuz you always got to get that jumping
it's a big thing it's to analyze and
what you did go in the season what you
did well what you did bad and things you
need to improve on coach congratulations
and enjoy the offseason as much as you
can and thanks for joining us Fischer
Florida State head coach they open up
with Alabama September 2nd in Atlanta
Continental Tire Coach's Corner
brought to you by Continental Tire
see Continental Tire at the sporting
venues across the United States proud
sponsor of college basketball
Continentals premium products available
at leading independent tire dealers car
dealers and mass retail companies across
North America great folks for more
information visit Continental Tire Comm
Continental Tire for what you do the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]